not it it is it is a little
mind-boggling all right so we're looking
outside and you can now see some early
light you can also see some very very
light showers out there too
a little bit of virga falling from the
clouds so a little rain coming down
that's not hitting the ground so we have
kind of layers of clouds as well
still have that cold air aloft and so
some of this
moisture is turning into snow and will
we see a few flakes flying around well
the closer
you live out to the foothills foothill
areas
the better chance but but it is very
limited moisture at this
at this hour we've got 40 up at aliante
but some mid 30s out in the summerlin
area
34 at mountains edge 37 in seven hills
so it's chilly grab some
grab a nice warm jacket make sure the
kids are wrapped up for school
something nice and warm this morning
we'll have sunshine after we get
probably through the lunch hours some
good sunshine but this morning it's cold
33 in prom 34 up in caliani calini and
lincoln county stand a good chance of
getting snow showers and rain showers
again today 36 in boulder city
46 in laughlin right now so as i showed
you going to break
just traces for official rainfall
yesterday
we're still about three quarters of an
inch behind for the year but
wow way ahead for the month two thirds
of an inch
so that's good but look at the
neighborhoods who scored some nice rain
yesterday
between henderson and boulder city over
a tenth of an inch those
showers and thunderstorms really focused
on the east side of town
with this system this is the latest
radar though right now we've got some
very light showers all along i-15
up in the moapa valley stretching out
from mesquite almost down to the las
vegas valley now
it's not a lot of moisture and we again
we're not even seeing all of it hit the
ground what we are seeing right now
within the valley
but some of this is turning to snow and
it is just so
so light and i don't think even any
neighborhoods on the west side are
seeing any snowflakes right now
yesterday showers
and thunderstorms rotating off eastern
clark county
northwest arizona mohave county had some
really good lightning with it as well
and then turning into snow last night
out of far hills
and town center seeing some snow last
night but you can see we're just on the
tail end
of the system now and it has to spin its
way out of here
so we're on the back side of that
spinning low so lincoln county you
again going to get some good rain and
snow today and then up into utah
as well as northern arizona maybe just a
few showers left for us through the
morning and then the afternoon looks
great
with sunshine and low 60s the system
clears out
boy we look great lucky tomorrow with
good sunshine for st patrick's day
our last week of winter closes out
friday look at those upper 70's
spring arrives saturday morning and then
a first chance of spring showers on
sunday with
temperatures back into the 60's for a
day or two